hi guys separate again and today I have
for you a time-lapse of a making of an
elven village in this park it's very
heavily inspired by Rivendell I would
say a lot of Rivendell ish elements in
it it's gonna be a couple of houses and
also a fun little pavilion and the
general sort of elven style that I had
going with the station I'll be just a
bit more refined and experimenting with
it just a little bit more and that's
basically everything that's going on and
there's not that much more to say about
that but there is something that I do
know talk about in this video a little
bit and that is some criticism that I've
been getting but it also relates to the
general idea of what I want to make in
this park and also more specifically
what I want to make with this little
village and it refers to the general
idea I think that this is very much a
fantasy like Park and this is something
I've never stated that explicitly or
that much what I mean with that and it
goes beyond just the fact that I am just
building something with a fantasy like
theme which the elven theme obviously is
but more that the general park layouts
is more fantasy like I try to be
realistic with the roller-coaster layout
itself and the idea behind the ride but
I would say a pretty important deal and
what makes this entire ride so much more
of a fantasy like ride and something
that I've rarely tried before actually
is that it doesn't so much follow the
general theme park rules it wouldn't
really fit inside a theme park either I
think it just goes overly expensive with
the theming and the way that in general
it's set up and I think this is most
clearly reflected in the fact that the
scenery which I'm making including while
the costs on top of the rock but to a
lesser extent also these houses I'm
building here is that it's scenery it's
more or less going to be a landscape
it's going to be a setting for the
coaster a kind of backdrop for it and
definitely a lot of fun to build and
just a general style that I've been
wanting to try in the game for a very
long time but it's exactly that it feels
like very fantasy like scenery a
landscape almost as if you're looking at
an elven village in
all of the rings and it's more this kind
of fantasy elven village idea than being
a theme park section with an elven theme
to it and the way I mean that is really
that it is a backdrop doesn't really
interact with the coaster directly it
doesn't directly interact with any parts
it doesn't have a coaster going around
or through the castle for instance and
these buildings don't actually have
rides or shops in them and they're
placed on a hill which makes them that
much more part of like a scenic
landscape instead of being buildings of
a theme park and I think even though
this seems like a small deal it's what
makes this ride kind of unrealistic and
that much of a fantasy ride in in the
sense that I'm just going beyond what a
theme park would regularly do like you
would want to make sure that you use
your space and money efficiently so you
want to have as much as you can within
the buildings and set up the theme park
very in a very compact way and make the
most of the building months that you
have whereas in this case I just make
the scene a lot bigger have these houses
on Hills and add so much detailing to
them which realistically a theme park
just wouldn't be doing and I'm not
stepping into the fantasy realm of love
floating islands or of ridiculously
large castles but more or less in a
sense of something that is just a little
bit more towards the fantasy of actual
elven village and magical castles than
the way that they're portrayed in theme
parks and the way this kind of relates
to some of the criticism that I've been
getting as well is well actually I say
some but I've only been getting one
comments about this and one comment
relating to the part is that I don't
really interact with the scenery over
here like the castle stands on top of a
rock and it doesn't actually do anything
with a coaster it's mostly just kind of
because I have that clashing idea behind
having this landscape where I focus low
on the scenery on the buildings and the
foliage and on creating this overall
picture of the elven village with a
castle yet on the other hand I also want
to just make a coaster and have that in
this valley and I just figured it
wouldn't really fit to have the cows to
go around the cows or underneath
for one it's just way too large and it
was pretty much impossible to do with
the inverted coaster here I also was
kind of annoyed by the supports of the
inverted coaster which has become
incredibly large if you race the
inverted coaster a lot like I feel it's
pretty fine right now since the coasters
are always very close to the ground and
you don't have to worry about the
supports that much but if you try and
make a really tall inverted coaster and
planet coaster supports go absolutely
everywhere so yeah that's actually a bit
of feedback I would give some vertical
support would be great or at least some
more vertically slanted supports but
anyway that didn't really work out in
the end so we kind of have the coaster
sits inside a sort of fantasy like
landscape but I didn't want it to you
know go through buildings or anything
like that I wanted to at least have a
bit of separation between the landscape
and the coaster in that sense and that
kind of breaks the theme park idea where
you want to make the most of your
buildings like both of the buildings
you'll see around the coaster either
shops or or the station itself or gift
shops or kind of restaurants and that
kind of idea doesn't really apply here
since it's just it's just a setting for
the coaster to be in and initially high
up with the paths as well is that in a
theme park you would see very wide paths
with things around it everywhere with
rice right in the middle of it and shops
along the sides and restaurants pretty
much everywhere whereas the paths in
this park just kind of flow through this
valley which is nice and all but it's
not really really realistic for a theme
park where you would more or less see
very large wide-open plazas with rides
and restaurants on them instead of these
paths that just kind of make they're
very curvy ready through a forest and
through valleys so there's a major
difference over there as well so I would
say while this might look somewhat like
a theme park to someone who doesn't who
isn't really as much into theme parks
there is definitely a lot of fantasy to
this hello of elven magic I guess I
might call it
but yeah that is basically the best
explanation I can give for why I'm doing
this coaster or at least the way that I
am doing it and the reason why I am
doing it this way is just because I've
been wanting to try a more fantasy and
lose from like reality kind of projects
for quite a while it's just fun
sometimes I figured to just get rid of
all those restrictions and just do
whatever you feel like would look really
cool so this is the only kind of thing
that I want to try with that my next
project I do want to try by the way I
hope it's gonna be something like a
universal islands of adventure
I think discovery world inside one is
actually a good idea of the scale and
type of park that I want to go for even
though it's got a rebranding lately it's
the Taiwanese park that's pretty famous
for gravity max but it's a small coast a
small Park which is quite similar to
Universal and that it has a lake in the
middle of it and different themed
sections it's just a bit smaller and
it's that kind of pre-planned Park that
I'm gonna try and keep very close to
realism in the future but for now this
is to a smile go crazy and do whatever
is cool kind of project so yeah that is
basically the idea behind the project
that's not to say that I don't
appreciate feedback as always I do but
there's one problem with this series in
that I'm doing this in a very short time
span and these videos are already kind
of behind the progress that I'm actually
making and so while I can usually just
listen and apply to any constructive
criticism at the moment it's just nearly
impossible for me to actually do so
because by the time that your comments
will reach me I'll already be way far
ahead in this coaster and in just a few
days the deadline is already there so
there's not a lot that I can like change
and tweak based on feedback on this
right so that's one thing to keep in
mind anyway I hope that entire story
made at least a little bit of sense to
get back to what I'm actually building
over here and explain a little bit more
about this building I figured this would
be nice to have sort of like the
soundhole
kind of main building to this little
village it's not going to be a really
big village I don't
go completely over the top it's just
gonna have a few houses in there but I
still want to make it as large as I can
without having to add too many buildings
as I can and just by placing it as I on
a hill that kind of works as well to
have these terraces underneath the
buildings but also kind of give the
village a bit of height and depth
without having to add too many buildings
around it just have a couple of
different buildings on a couple of
different heights and rotations that's
the general idea and I did want to place
the biggest most important kind of first
building on top of that hill and make
sure that that's the highest most
visible building and that is basically
right away done over there though I did
want to add one more thing to it that is
a clock tower or a bell tower actually I
should say just to make it a little bit
more fancy but also a general idea
behind this is and this is pretty
important you don't see me doing it in
the time lapses since I cut quite a bit
of this out of it but since this village
is gonna be more of like a landscape
kind of idea instead of being like this
functional cute little village on its
own I did want to fit it neatly into the
into the landscape so on top of this
hill but also make sure that it looks
good in combination with a castle so I
took a couple of like main sight lines
sort of observation points if you will
from the paths from which I figured I
wanted to have some shots of the village
and kind of looked at how the village
would look from those points and the
most important thing that I wanted to do
with this is sort of got a gradual curve
toward the castle the issue that I had
at this point is that the console is
already a very tall building but it also
sits on top of this very tall rock and I
really felt if I wouldn't add anything
around it the console would stand on its
own too much and look too much like a
sort of very single lonely building and
instead of that I wanted to have a sort
of gradually curving upwards kind of
idea of the scenery so you have really
small buildings all the way at the side
that kind of fade away if
look from a distance and the larger and
more Towery pointy err buildings toward
the castle and then the castle as a sort
of final crescendo of that little thing
I know it sounds really ridiculous but
you'll see the idea once I actually
start sharing the cinematic shots at the
end of this video the idea is basically
to have this slowly rising wall of
buildings toward the console where the
console is gonna be the highest points
and all the buildings to what this side
from there kind of gradually get lower
and lower to create just a nice sort of
symmetrical looking landscape especially
as you enter the park because of one of
the sight lines then I chose to kind of
make this from the entrance is actually
one so as you enter this park you
actually see the castle ride ahead and
you kind of see the village and the
station on either side of the castle
kind of gradually curving down into the
hills of the trees that go around this
area and that's the general idea of how
I wanted to more or less divide the
landscape that's also why I won't go out
of my way to make the entire area just
one big clogged elven village because
the idea is to have most of the
buildings on this side and just make the
rest of the landscape some trees and
some other things that I can play around
with like waterfalls because well I can
take some inspiration from Rivendell as
well as inspiration from nemesis with
that and maybe a tree house that's
something I kind of want to get into if
I have some time left for it as well
though again I haven't really set this
so far but I'm obviously on a very
strict deadline with this project as
well so I'm kind of in a hurry with
getting this done and I felt that's
something that kind of plays along with
making this as well I added the tower
over here to this building to the left
just to add a nice little well not a
nice little a pretty big accents on the
building on the left here to make sure
that big castle doesn't look so alone
and to kind of have that transition into
the high peaks of the castle
and in front of this building I wanted
to have this kind of Hanging Gardens
idea by playing with the hillside here
but at the same time having some flat
space for flowers and trees to make it
all fancy so there's a few terraces over
here with these walls and little pots
between them building the division
between that's I actually worked on that
for quite a while there and skipped
forward just a bit to ending this little
house in here which it's going to be a
very simple house and it's not going to
actually have any walls it's just gonna
have some pillars around this but it's
gonna be nice to add a bit of extra
depth to this area and make sure that
this village is a bit closer to the path
and especially because it's pretty much
quite far ahead of the larger building
in the back it just adds a bit more
attempt to the town I felt that's just
the idea behind and in this house here
what's also kind of interesting about
this is that Rivendell really has liked
a lot of what you see of Rivendell is
the arches you don't actually see any
walls with windows in them if you look
from a distance you just kind of see
endless arches and pillars with roofs on
top of them and that's also the kind of
impression that I wanted to give with
many of these buildings but I didn't
want to quite go for that hence why I
wanted to have as many layers of
different arches as I could with as
little of the amount of space as I could
so while this building is still an open
work building you can actually see on
the building in the back I added those
long very tall arched windows behind
already-existing
while a double row of arches to kind of
give that idea of an endless Gaelic
gallery of arches and pillars without
actually having to make one and saving
myself at least a bit of time and
computer issues in the process and I'm
pretty happy with how that turned out
and a lot of this is also just
decorating the garden a little bit more
with some simple fences and flowers and
things like that
one of the issues that I do have with
this is that many of the details that
I'm well working with at the moment are
White's
and we can't recover anything in the
game so far
you more or less just had to work with
the colors that we have and kind of try
to fit different pieces together to get
slightly different color schemes but
there's no moving away from the color
schemes that we have at the moment is
even though we can make many shapes with
them that's just pretty much a given
right now and I wanted to bring back
those whites a little bit by just having
as much foliage as I can here and why I
didn't want to make these garlands
pretty densely foliage if that is a word
and edit all of these hanging baskets
and flower pots and planters things like
that all around these gardens and the
houses to add some greenery and more
color to these I also figured it would
be nice to make a quick custom little
shrub with the three branches actually
reckon they're really good for making
different kinds of shrubs I haven't
looked into it very much but you can
basically combine it with many of the
plants just use the driftwood and some
of the different plants elements and you
can actually make some really creative
stuff even well custom trees though
that's something that's for a well
future episode and I'm not going to
spoil that quite yet but I'm looking
into treehouses I kind of spoiled my
idea there anyway but yeah that's that's
the idea that I'm still looking into
anyway moving on to the last build of
this time-lapse and this is well
actually in the end it turned out to be
one of my favorites I didn't really
expect it beforehand I wasn't really
sure how this would turn out it's
basically going to be a small pavilion
if you know River now you know that like
pavilion that's down there with a lot
like openwork decorations on top of it
and it's that kind of idea which I
wanted to try here of course it's a bit
different and I really couldn't work
with the details that are used in
Rivendell given the pieces that we have
and the fact that many of the pieces are
quite clunky but I wanted to make a
classical pavilion with some pillars
around it and a dome on top of it over
here and this is basically my try at
doing so and for the openwork in the
middle just to make it more fancy and
more interesting and give it a bit of
density to the dome as well without
adding an actual roof because I think
especially openwork like this is
quite common for Alvin kind of
architecture so something I really
wanted to mess around with and even
though it turned out to be kind of hard
to cut these things into the exact
position that I wanted it's just gonna
make this don't look like it actually
has the shape of a dome and has some
interesting details of the roof while at
the same time keeping it see-through so
you can see the things behind it and it
doesn't really obstruct the view or
anything it still blends in quite nicely
with the pretty dense area around it as
well and that's the idea behind this
little preferring over here aside from
the obviously different term though it's
pretty similar to what I've already had
at this point in time it's just the dome
that's sort of like the new thing over
here I've also had the question of
whether I could make a bridge like the
one in River now if you know about River
now there's this bridge which shares the
roof design with the pavilion over there
which is a really cool bridge like it
has these very nice arches above it also
has arches underneath it and like big
waterfalls but that's just I guess just
on too big of a scale to really make it
happen here like I do still want to keep
it on a somewhat manageable scale but I
am in the end quite happy with how this
Bavarian turnouts also I do need to
preserve some space there's not a lot of
space left between the coasters hence
why I don't want to theme too much
between them simply because it's hard to
do so and much of the scenery is gonna
have to be just around these areas and
there's definitely no room around the
roller coasters to mess around with very
large bridges or anything like that and
another issue is that at this point I've
got so many sight lines that I kind of
want to keep around and kind of want to
keep open and pretty much safe from
foliage or buildings or anything that
could block the view that there are a
lot of like protected areas within this
valley that where I don't build anything
to prevent losing the view so there
aren't too many other areas where I'll
be building a lot so this village is
gonna set most of the scene in terms of
having buildings there are quite a few
that I still have like I already have
the castle and the station and there are
gonna be a few that I should hopefully
still plant around not to mention that
there are some flat rides as well but
this is gonna be most of it since much
of the focus is just on the roller
coasters themselves and like I said this
is more or less just the kind of
backdrop and scenery thing that I really
really wanted to try but it doesn't
exactly translate well into having it
around the roller coaster itself and
going to complicated into the scenery
and I'm finishing this off just a bit of
foliage around this area to make it look
a bit nicer I'll get into big forests on
those hills but this is just a quick
start and the small fence around here
anyway that is right about it's for the
time-lapse part today but I do still
have some cinematic shots saved so I'll
share those and with that I'm going to
end this video so thank you guys for
watching I hope to see you guys next
time